les artistes de la musique réunionnaise
se sont vus remettre l'album rois et
reines au théâtre de champ fleuri ce
jeudi 27 octobre
un album qui reprend l'exposition qui
leur est consacré des portraits
photographiques des témoignages en toute
intimité a commencé avec firmin viry qui
me demande pour son jubilé pour ses 80
ans de faire une photo un peu plus
intimiste que celle qu'on pouvait avoir
déduit sur internet une photo c'est
avant tout une rencontre c'est arrivé à
voir une photo un peu naturel parlante
plein d'émotion bien il faut qu'il faut
parler avec le faut arriver à vivre un
moment d'émotion et donc ses intimes et
à partir de là on s'est dit ben tiens
pourquoi ne pas ne pas faire ça pousser
plus loin l'aventuré et rencontré un
petit peu tous et tous ces grands de la
scène réunionnaise
une fois le boulot d'été on n'est pas
des cris du juste ainsi pour grandir
encore et les bronchites à doha où
c'était inacceptable
et après tout ce n'était pas pour
nassimah dindar présidente du
département il est important de rendre
hommage à ces jeunes musiciens et
danseurs qui ont consacré leur vie à
faire vivre les traditions artistiques
réunionnaise ce sont les représentants
de la musique réunionnaise d'hier
d'aujourd'hui est vraisemblablement
encore de demain et sont la mémoire
immatériel et en corse au nord de ce
qu'est l'identité musicale créole voire
même au delà de la zone océan indien
on rend hommage à des artistes au fond
ce sont eux qui rendent hommage à tous
les réunionnais avec leur musique
avec les mots qui font chanter qu'il
faut danser il faut danser le coeur des
réunionnais depuis des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années dans témoignages mais
on peut le dire l'émotion et la joie de
ses compagnons de l'histoire et le
plaisir qu'ils tirent de cette légitime
reconnaissance à prendre mon temps du
temps car à lire comment on dire que
quand
comme ça avec conseil général pour - dia
qui fait passer au caire au contraire
c'est un grande émotion c'est un grand
plaisir
ouah ça comme ça ce fut sûrement au
caire métro canada - ovale à ce niveau
là me vois le cleri puis rouvert ici
comme au léman ou encore à la moyenne ou
mal roulé bons amis tous trois nient
vous n'êtes pas pas dans le ciel i'm on
one man show mais j'ai créé about
royaume pour nous vivons nous voulons
dire